another sign of russian aggression
against civilians in ukraine a bombing
of a theater in the besieged city of
mariopol
the number of casualties is not yet
known but local officials say hundreds
of people were sheltering there
these satellite images show the theater
a few days before the bombing the
russian word for children spelt out on
the ground
russia's defense ministry has denied
carrying out the attack
following another day of violence u.s
president joe biden has for the first
time called russian leader vladimir
putin a war criminal
comments which the kremlin has described
as unacceptable and unforgivable
but peace talks between russia and
ukraine are ongoing
the mayor of mellitupole who was
kidnapped by russian forces last week
has been released according to ukrainian
officials they say it was part of an
exchange that saw ukraine agree to hand
over nine captured russian soldiers
there is cautious optimism that progress
is being made
my priorities for the negotiations are
absolutely clear
the end of the war guarantees of
security sovereignty restoration of
territorial integrity real guarantees
for our country
real protection for our country
but shells continue to fall on ukrainian
cities and all people can do is hide
if the thought of cowering children
doesn't stop the russian bombardment
what will